mister president secretary der
exzellenten meine sehr verehrten damen
und herren
ein kleines baby ist in einer u bahn
station in kehrt zur welt gekommen das
war vor einigen tagen
sie wurde auf den namen getauft die
familie musste zuflucht dort suchen wie
auch millionen von anderen menschen in
der ukraine schutz vor raketen vermieter
panzern und granaten sie leben in angst
sie leben im land sie müssen sich von
ihren geliebten menschen trennen warum
weil russland einen brutalen krieg gegen
die ukraine gestartet hat meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren ich glaube
die abstimmung von heute betrifft mehr
es geht um die zukunft unserer kinder es
geht um die zukunft die wir auswählen
ich stehe hier vor ihn
als außenministerin meines landes aber
ich stehe hier auch als deutsche die das
immense privileg gehabt hat in frieden
und sicherheit in europa aufwachsen zu
können nach dem zweiten weltkrieg
nach einem brutalen krieg den nazi
deutschland gestartet hat wurden die
vereinten nationen gegründet vor 76
jahren zur wahrung von frieden und
sicherheit in der welt gegründet wie es
in der vater heißt um den folgenden
generationen
die geißel des krieges zu ersparen um
generationen wie ich es bin zu schützen
aber auch eine generation wie die von
mir die grundsätze der vereinten
nationen liefern den rahmen für unseren
frieden
eine regelbasierte ordnung völkerrecht
zusammengeschlossen und eine friedliche
beilegung von konflikten
russland hat diese ordnen brutal
angegriffen und aus diesen gründen geht
es in diesem krieg nicht nur um die
ukraine oder in europa es geht um uns
alle
russland
angriff ist eine zeitenwende ein
scheidepunkt
wenigen tagen sind diese sicherheiten
weg wir waren in einer neuen realität
auf und niemand hat ihre wirklichkeit
gewählt diese realität
hat uns präsident putin aufgezwungen der
krieg von russland ist ein aggressions
krieg und er beruht auf lügen
außenminister lavrov hat sie heute in
genf bei einem
menschenrechtskommissariat nochmal
wiederholt und hat von
legitimer notwehr gesprochen aber wir
wissen dass das nicht stimmt sie haben
diesen angriff monatelang vorbereitet
sie sagen dass russland
russischsprachige menschen schützen muss
aber heute sieht die gesamte welt
während sie die wohngebiete in kharkiv
angreifen mit bomben sie sagen sie
kommen in frieden aber ihre panzer haben
kein wasser haben keine lebensmittel für
babys ihre panzer tragen keinen frieden
emsig ihre panzer bringen zerstörung und
tod
sie missbrauchen ihre macht als
ständiges mitglied im sicherheitsrat
hella ruf sie können sich nicht selbst
belügen vielleicht tun sie das aber uns
können sie nicht belügen und sie können
auch unsere
menschen nicht täuschen und auch nicht
ihre eigene bevölkerung
der russische krieg steht für eine neue
realität
und verlangt von uns allen
verantwortungsbewusste haltung
einzunehmen und farbe zu bekennen wir
verstärken unsere hilfe in für
lebensmittel für arzneimittel und für
schutz unterkünfte für flüchtlinge
viele von uns tun das und ich würdige
das und danke ihnen dafür
es gibt gerüchte die auch hier die runde
gemacht haben dass menschen die die
ukraine verlassen aus von afrikanischer
herkunft sind dass sie an den eu-grenzen
diskriminierung erfahren haben haben
heute morgen war ich in polen und
zusammen mit meinem französischen und
polnischen kollegen haben wir es klar
gesagt jeder geflüchtete muss schutz
bekommen ungeachtet seiner nationalität
ungeachtet seiner herkunft
ungeachtet seiner hautfarbe
wir haben entschieden die ukraine auch
militärisch zu unterstützen
damit die ukraine sich gegen den
aggressor verteidigen kann in einklang
mit artikel
51 der vater deutschland ist sich seiner
historischen verantwortung bewusst und
aus diesem grunde werden wir immer und
der diplomatie verpflichtet fühlen auf
der suche nach friedlichen lösungen
aber wenn unsere friedensordnung
attackiert wird dann müssen wir
verantwortungsvoll handeln handeln und
die augen öffnen und deswegen müssen wir
uns heute hinter dem ziel frieden
versammeln als ich die gesamte welt in
den letzten tagen am telefon hatte da
ging es um die solidarität von europa
aber wo waren sie für uns in der
vergangenheit und ganz offen gesagt
sie sollten wissen wir hören sie ich
höre sie und ich bin fest davon
überzeugt dass wir unser eigenes handeln
immer bereit sein sollten kritisch zu
hinterfragen auch unsere vergangenen
engagement in der welt und ich bin zu
diesem kritischen hinterfragen bereit
aber es geht jetzt um jetzt
es geht um zuflucht finden in
u-bahn-stationen warum weil die wohnung
verbannt wird es geht hier um das leben
und das tut und den tod der ukrainischen
bevölkerung
es geht um die sicherheit in europa
es geht um unsere gemeinsame vater der
vereinten nationen
dass jedes land der welt ist hier
vertreten und sie haben alle einen
machtvollen großen starken nachbarn und
damit geht es um uns alle und deswegen
fordere ich sie alle mit nachdruck auf
dass sie sich hinter dem ziel frieden
versammeln und dass sie die
vorgeschlagene resolution
bejahen und dafür stimmen
bitte entscheiden sie sich
nicht für ungerechtigkeit sondern für
gerechtigkeit so hattest bischof desmond
tutu mal gesagt
wir müssen jetzt farbe bekennen
wir müssen uns entscheiden zwischen
frieden und aggressionen zwischen
gerechtigkeit und das recht des
stärkeren
zwischen handeln und wegschauen
wenn wir nach der abstimmung nach hause
fahren dann sollten wir alle bereit sein
unseren kindern und partnern in die
augen zu schauen auch unseren freunden
und verwandten
und das am küchentisch denn genau da
müssen
wir bereit sein diesen menschen in die
augen zu schauen und sagen für was wir
uns hier entschieden haben